- [Instructor] What we're going
to talk about in this video
is Voter Turnout.
Which is a way of thinking about, well,
how many of the people who
could vote actually do vote?
It's often expressed as a
number, as a percentage,
where you have the number
who vote, number who vote,
over the number of eligible voters.
Number who could vote, who could vote.
And this percentage
varies pretty dramatically
from region to region, amongst
various demographic groups,
we'll talk about that in a few minutes,
and especially if you think about,
even sometimes year to year
and from country to country.
There's some countries
that have mandatory voting,
where this number is a lot higher,
other countries, for various reasons,
this number could be lot lower.
And one thing for you to think about
if you're already of voting age,
you might have already thought this,
or if you're not voting
yet, you will soon,
what would drive you to vote,
or what would drive you to not vote?
Stay home, or somehow
keep you from engaging
in this political process.
Well one thing that you'll
often hear folks say is
does my vote matter?
Does my vote matter?
And the typical response that
you would get if you say that
is well if everyone thought that,
then democracy really won't function,
so yes, your vote does matter.
So that's the high-level
way of thinking about it,
but everyone thinks about
this to a certain degree.
And this idea of thinking
about whether your vote matters
a fancy way of describing that
is you're thinking about
your Political Efficacy.
Political efficacy.
Fancy political science term,
but it's really just this idea of
what's my belief about how
politically effective I can be
when I vote.
If I am in a battleground
State, say Florida,
where even Presidential Elections
have turned on a few hundreds of votes,
in Florida, you might say, hey,
I have high political efficacy.
My vote does matter there.
But some folks who live in a State
that may be strongly leaning
towards one party or another
during a Presidential Election,
say a California, that
tends to go to a Democrat,
or say a Texas, that tends
to go to a Republican,
regardless of which party you are,
you'd say, well if I'm just one more
Republican vote in Texas,
does my vote matter?
If I'm one more Democratic
vote in California,
does my vote matter?
I would encourage you in both
cases, your vote does matter.
If everyone believed that,
then our democracy does not function.
Now a related idea to political efficacy
is this idea of just
how engaged are people?
So I'll call that engagement.
And this might be, well
how much do they care?
So beyond does my vote matter,
there's a notion of do I care?
There are certain elections
where you might really like one candidate
or might really dislike another candidate.
You might think, hey, there's
some big issues on the table
that rally affect my life.
So I might be more engaged.
Or frankly, the various candidates,
or the various political parties
or community organizations
might just be better at
engaging the population.
Now a third dimension
beyond whether people
believe their vote matters
or how engaged they are in
the issues or the candidates
is the structure around voting itself.
What State Laws are there around voting,
and how easy or how hard is it to vote?
So, for example, if there's
a big window of time
where people can vote,
and if the polling places
are really accessible,
especially if they're
available on say a holiday,
then it might be easier for
people to actually go to vote.
But on the other hand, if
they aren't that accessible,
or if it's on a day where a lot
of folks might need to work,
or certain demographics
might need to work,
well they might be less
likely to turn out.
You also have laws
around absentee ballots,
or people being able
to vote ahead of time.
The easier it is logistically to vote,
the more accessible it is,
you're gonna get a higher turnout.
Now political scientists
don't just study voter turnout
to understand the past.
They look at the past
to try and make predictions
about the future.
The next Congressional Election,
the next Presidential Election,
if they're trying to figure
out which way it might go,
you can't just survey
people alone and say,
well are you gonna vote for
this candidate or that candidate
because you also have to think about
how likely are they to vote.
And that likelihood could
be based on various factors.
It might be based on their age,
it might be based on their race,
it might be based on
their education level.
And to appreciate that,
let's start taking a look at some data.
This chart right over here
shows voter turnout by sex and age
in the 2008 US Presidential Election,
where the blue bars are males,
and the red bars are females.
And then you can see the
different age groups.
And so pause this video.
It's just fun to look at these things.
What take-aways are there here?
Well, you can see if you look at
all of the eligible voters,
total, 18 years and over,
that women had a higher
voter turn-out than men.
60.4% of eligible women
vote, only 55.7% of men.
Think about why that might be.
What beliefs might women have
around their own political
efficacy relative to men?
Maybe they're more engaged,
maybe there's issues on the table
that they care more about.
And then if you look by age group,
that trend tends to be true.
It's most pronounced at
the younger age groups,
but then things get more and more equal
as we go to the older age groups.
The only place where
that trend breaks down
is in 75 years and over.
And then you also have the general trend
that older folks are more likely to vote.
Once again, why is that?
Here's another interesting chart.
This is voter turnout by
educational attainment,
for the same US
Presidential Election, 2008.
So you can see that on average,
across all education levels,
you have this voter turnout around 58.2%,
but the more educated people get,
the more they're likely, or
at least in that election,
the more likely they
were to actually vote.
The more educated people are,
they might feel more engaged,
they might have a better belief
that their vote is effective
so they have a belief
around political efficacy.
This is voter turnout in the
2008 US Presidential Election
by race and ethnicity.
And so here you see that in that election,
White voters had 64.8%
turnout, Black voters 60.8%,
and you can see Asian and Hispanic voters
were much, much lower.
What does this say about
political engagement,
and what does it say
about their beliefs
around political efficacy?
And to see trends over time,
I'm going to go to the
site of FairVote.org,
which is a really great
non-partisan non-profit
that is trying to think about
how to we get a better democracy.
So this diagram right over here
shows voter turnout
rates from 1916 to 2016.
And there's two different lines here.
The top one is in Presidential Elections,
this is the 2016 Presidential Election,
and this bottom line right over here
is the Mid-Term elections.
So this is where there isn't
someone running for president.
Why do you think that
there's such a big gap here?
That pretty consistently,
you have a much higher voter turnout
in this, depending on
what year you look at,
but say in 2016, you
have a 60% voter turnout,
while in the Mid-Term Election of 2014,
you didn't even break 40%.
You had little under 36% voter turnout.
Why do you think you have this big gap?
Well you could probably
turn to these ideas
of political efficacy and engagement.
One thing that people talk
about around Congressional Seats
is that there tends to not be
a lot of turnover around it.
In other videos, we've talked about
how the districts might be
shaped to benefit incumbents,
the entire process might
be benefiting incumbents,
so people might say, hey,
I have a very low political efficacy here.
Most Congresspeople
tend to stay in office,
so maybe that's why they
don't really go out to vote,
and there might be an
engagement thing going on,
that on Presidential years,
where also Congresspeople
are up for re-election,
or up for election,
the reason why people go out to vote
is that Presidential Elections
are these really big dramatic things,
they take over the press,
they take over everyone's attention.
Now another interesting thing
to think about is the trend.
Why, say, in Presidential Elections,
actually in Presidential
and in Mid-Term Elections,
do you have such high
engagement in the 1960s,
relative to, say, the 1980s and 1990s,
where things got pretty low?
One argument could be
that the 1960s was a time
of very high political engagement.
You had the Vietnam War going on,
you had the Civil Rights Movement.
Now if we scroll down on
FairVote right over here,
we can see voter turnout in
the 2016 elections by State.
And the deeper the purple
here, the higher the turnout.
And so what patterns do you see here?
And I'll give you a hint.
Think about which States
are battleground States.
The ones that could flip either way,
or the ones that could
have flipped either way
in the 2016 election.
Well you can see the deeper purple
are on States like Florida,
or in States like Ohio,
or Wisconsin and (mumbles), Michigan.
These are indeed battleground States.
So you can imagine folks in those States
believed that they had
higher political efficacy.
Now in the 2014 elections,
you don't see it as dramatic.
This is a Mid-Term election year.
So people are thinking a lot less
about the Electoral College
and Presidential Elections,
so it isn't as all or nothing
as they are in the Electoral College
in the Presidential Elections,
so you don't see it as pronounced.
But if you go back to 2012,
which was a Presidential Election year,
you see the same pattern again.
That the battleground
States are a deeper color.
So I will leave you there.
You should vote, that's just
my public service message,
but it's interesting to think about
why, in general, voter
turnout might change.